You have two new projects out.
One is "Minx." I'm obsessed.
It's a cheeky comedy that presents women
in a multidimensional way.
There's a character.
She wants to start like a feminist magazine,
but she meets Jake Johnson, who's so cute and adorable,
and he runs like lady magazines.
It matriculates into them making a magazine for women.
Yeah.
With male.
Naked men, exactly.
Why is the male body trending right now, Paul?
(Paul laughs)
Like you watch HBO, "Euphoria," "Minx,"
like these projects,
(audience laughs)
like what is it about women
and men who are all of a sudden like,
you know what would be the greatest trend ever?
(Paul laughs)
Males.
(Paul and audience laughing)
I think it's because it hasn't been done a lot
in the past.
There haven't been a lot of like full-frontal men
in movies and TV.
(audience member laughs)
No, there really hasn't been.
Exactly.
It's not like a trend. It's like a revelation.
Who knew what guys were packing, right?
(Drew and audience laughing)
Well, we all knew.
Just apparently, we didn't wanna see it.
Now we realize, we got a bite of the apple, Paul,
and we want more.
(Paul and audience laughing)
(audience applauds)
So congratulations.
Cheers, thank you.
And thank you
for bringing that to the forefront.
Now "Welcome to Flatch" is a beautiful show
that feels in keeping with you when I think of two tones
that are my personal North Stars and most important,
which is heart and humor.
Mm-hmm.
What spoke to you about this project?
And what should we be thinking as we watch it going into it?
Well, like you say, heart and humor,
that's what I love about it.
It's based on a BBC show called "This Country,"
and this is the, we made an American version of it.
And it's about a small town.
I grew up in a small town in Michigan.
So we really love small towns and the people in them.
And this was a way to kind of show that off
and have fun with those people.
Not making fun of them, by any means.
Having fun with all the people.
You know, when you're in a small town,
it's like being in high school.
You're kind of trapped in this place with these people,
but then you have a love for those people.
And so it's a really sweet show, but it's very, very funny.
Yes, 100%.
(audience applauds)
Now I have to ask you as the last question,
when you met with Melissa McCarthy for "Bridesmaids,"
what did you see?
(audience laughs)
Ah, well, a brilliant person.
Actually, well, she comes in
and she started to do the audition,
and she did it so different
from the way anybody else did it,
it took me a good 10 to 15 seconds to realize it was funny
because I was literally going like, "What is she doing?"
And then you go like,
"I think this is the funniest thing I've ever seen."
Well, it led to an Academy Award nomination.
There you go.
Which in comedy,
(audience applauds)
is the hardest thing to do.
Yeah.
Paul Feig, "Welcome to Flatch" airs Thursday nights
on FOX with the first seven episodes streaming now on Hulu.
Also, check out the hit series, "Minx."
We're all gonna enjoy it.
(Paul laughs)
It's got new episodes available Thursdays on HBO Max,
who seems to know what everybody wants right now.
(Paul laughs)
Paul Feig, I'm your biggest fan.
Oh.
Thank you for coming
on the show.
Back at you, Drew. Thank.
(upbeat pop music)